all boys dream of becoming Knights the
boys with talent dream of becoming
Kingsguard the boys without talent well
I wouldn't know I remember the day the
Lord Commander wrote my name down in the
white book the official record of the
Kingsguard at 16 the youngest member
ever to join knighted by Sir Arthur and
sir Barristan for valor against the
Kingswood Brotherhood an outlaw had
decided to try snuck against a lowly
Squire he wasn't using his head so I
took it off him shortly afterwards King
Aerys ii who hadn't yet earned the title
of the Mad King took me into his service
if I have ever been happy it was that
day for centuries the King Scott had
been the glory of the realm Aegon the
Conqueror had established the order as
his personal Guardians after uniting
Westeros with fire and blood he knew
that some of his subjects wouldn't take
to conquest and his dragons were no use
against knives in the dark no doubt
surrounding himself with the greatest
nights in Westeros made his rule more
palatable and less foreign as well
everyone in this kingdom soon knew the
names and sung the songs of the King
Scott I certainly did from earliest days
Lord Commander jelled Hightower the
white ball Arthur Dayne the sword of the
morning Barristan Selmy the bold Prince
looing Martell gospel went jonatha Derry
and soon enough the boy prodigy me we
protect the king and his family we
killed his enemies and led his armies
we gave him counsel when asked and kept
his secrets were not we swore to hold no
lands take no wives and father no
children like the Nights Watch except
with a real job to do was I old to see
my name inscribed in the same book as my
heroes of course not I was 16 and
brilliant I knew it belonged there
beside the name of Prince Aemon the
dragonknight who wielded the Valyrian
sword dark sister he
died defending King Aegon the unworthy
from assassins though the King had
insulted a Mithu out his reign and had
well earned his fate
because Prince Amon had sworn out of
beside the name of Sir Gawain colbry
were jeweled it's a garyun bastard
daemon Blackfyre for an hour during the
battle at the Red Cross field though
outmatched and grievously wounded
because sick wing had Swan haloth beside
the name of Sir Duncan the tall who as a
hedge Knight broke several of Prince
aerion Targaryen teeth while defending a
Dornish woman he laid a roast in Lord
command and burned beside his king at
summer Hall because certain can had
sworn our oath and now below the name of
Jaime Lannister you know how it reads
what I did even though I had sworn our
oath that was years and a hand ago when
I joined the Kingsguard I fought beside
legends in the flesh their kind is dust
now and the men have taken their place
but sabores blunt the fat some Meryn
Trant the forgettable Santa claw gained
the dark tuck tail and ran like mud
their names soiled the white book almost
as much as my